so for you what is something that
because
you kind of were in the middle of the
peak of the dysfunction in terms of just
like if we were to think about like the
on camera drama and no jumper you were
pretty much there for all the all the
hits all the greatest hits a lot of them
so for you like is there anything that
you regret from that era or oh
absolutely like what absolutely but now
now to be fair a lot of that [__]
started before I was even in the mix
right and then you had nothing to do
with the house phone thing yeah yeah no
and then there were because prior to me
being even like
a prominent character over there
there is Tyrell and um there's the the
t-rell and uh Almighty suspect there's
like a lot of different things right
but
what I really regret because I feel like
going into January
we're on a very harmonious level
everybody was getting along we're all
[__] with each other we had that CR
you know that that video I posted
earlier was from the Christmas party
everybody's like we're one big happy
family right and then in the beginning
of January I wound up you know Adam told
you about it how he like encouraged me
to get at Flaco and [__] I regret I
should have never done that because that
completely violates my moral compass as
is a man in recovery like now I get
making fun of people is one thing joking
around we all can who ride each other
but I think that I took it way too far
and a lot and was did something that I
knew was wrong even though I was asked
to do it by my boss who I was trying to
you know who I wanted to be happy with
me but at the same time it wound up
setting in motion Not only was it wrong
to Flacco who I'm cool with now right
but to set an emotion a chain of events
which kind of led to what we're at right
now crazy a lot of people are saying
that you might be suing
I mean if I was I wouldn't talk about
that anyway right that's fair I was
gonna say because like I think like
there's a few ways to look at the whole
situation it's like if you Sue it's like
I mean I don't know if that bridge is
ever going to be unburned but it kind of
really burns the bridge absolutely I
mean I feel like there's no Bridge
there's no the bridge is over the bridge
the bridge is open but it's a Keras one
yeah yeah just South Bronx right here
can you feel me
um for people who don't know like kind
of give me your uh uh like roots in
terms of hip-hop and like getting
involved in the battle scene
um you know I've been involved in
hip-hop culture my whole life right um I
started started rapping when I was 15 in
the mid 90s
um used to go to Project load and things
like that and just like you know
elements was that on Tuesday night or
Thursday Thursday night yeah
I was too much of a kid but I always
heard about it yeah yeah yeah and I was
like you know I'm just soaking up the
game and soaking up culture moved uh
born and raised in Los Angeles moved to
the Bay Area to Oakland California when
I was 19 and that's really when my um
you know in career as a battle rapper
started I started off as a battle rapper
got a lot of Buzz locally and then it
started to grow bigger I was in a
popular uh local group called Delmon
crew at the time where we were pretty
much in Oakland in Oakland anytime there
would be what year was this this is like
uh from 2003 to you know that's like
yeah straight right Fiera yeah yeah yeah
so we were there I was there for the
whole entire hyping movement and kind of
like what we were as a crew shout out to
my brothers Plex Rock and Ajax um we
were like kind of anti-ant no no no no
no like we were like like if you saw the
way we dressed and [__] you would think
we were just regular hypey rappers but
we were super lyrical and like we would
do like boom bap tracks and then we
would do like hyphy turn up [__] like
too like we had music with Mr Fab and
all that and we had music with Jairo and
you know um Sean Price were the first
group from Oakland to do a song with
R.I.P Sean yeah shout out to Sean P man
so yeah and and that was like a whole
thing and then it wound up uh the battle
rap thing started popping off and um at
a certain point
in 2008 uh I linked up with this company
called Grind Time which was like the
first prominent battle rap fixture on
YouTube and I got to the point where and
they started in Florida me being from
the West Coast it was like look I know I
got some Talent as an MZ but I'm way
better as like a curator of culture and
organizer and a host and like just like
kind of you know what I mean so I wound
up and it wasn't even like that I was I
won't say that that was the most
organized of any of my friends but I was
at least disorganized so you were trying
to so essentially you got brought on to
grind time to help bring events together
yeah yeah and I won't ban the brand of
the West Coast yeah and this is right
when World Star Hip-Hop was popping off
we were on the front page of world star
every drop that we had Wanda blowing up
you know I remember that yeah people
like disaster dumbfounded no can do like
all you know a lot of the the great
lyricists of the West Coast and then um
daylight like and then I also brought a
lot of the top east coast rappers and
Midwest and south rappers to Cali to
battle for the first time Arsenal
conceded
um
T-Rex Calico like a lot of these dudes
got their averb had their first first
time hopping on a plane was through me
booking them out west the last I think
the last big battle I ever went to was
in Phoenix and it was when daylight took
a [__] in the desert yep yeah yeah were
you there
no or disasters here for people though
yeah yeah no no no
um but that was a seminal moment was it
I mean just for the [__] I just think
of like the viral moments that I
remember recently it was like that it
was like cannabis pulling out of [__]
I was a part of that yeah yeah he was
there for that and then even him
battling Cassidy I remember that which
and and those are both battles that I
curated as well